did you ever get close to doing anything
with Hove
no I never I don't even think I met him
crazy
that's crazy you would think
um for you because you've been doing a
lot of full collab albums I think back
to like one of the first producer
MC albums to me that I kind of just
heralded like very high in my life was
the first album you did with the the
Giza album it was a masterminds oh
Grandmasters Grand Masters yeah
um crazy body of work but you still like
you've done such a good job of like
doing these like fully you know cohesive
collaborative albums with other artists
I feel like a lot of people are kind of
doing that now as well 100 it wasn't on
it like that it wasn't on it you're kind
of to me like you're the first guy who
really kind of did that yeah they're
doing versus records yeah which is a um
Asia Ill Bill we did back in like what
2003 I think it was something like that
04. yeah me and jizz always click man
from the first day we got in the lab we
always clicked man and it was just
everything was smooth and easy and you
know we just kept communicating all
through the times you know and um kept
in touch and then we then we got
together into Grand Masters but it was a
weird time because at that time it was
right after Napster and the [__] the
whole ass fell out the music industry so
yeah we went from selling under ground
records 250 000 records to sell in
[__] 5 000 records so it was before
YouTube it was before Spotify it was
before Apple music yeah and then the
music the records weren't selling so you
was there was like this three or four
year period we was like what the [__]
going on bro how do we how do we
monetize this nobody knew what was going
on yeah it was a weird ass time you know
what I mean so all I know is you just
stay consistent and just keep going
that's the one thing about my crew Man
From Me Al cartoon estevon Cypress we
just never stopped yeah you just never
stopped through it all I was gonna ask
you
um what is something that you've because
you're obviously uh you like you said
there was that point in time where
you've been a part of every
for the most part era of hip-hop in
terms of like the way the business is
right like you guys first came home with
soundscan hit now fast 80s like 80s my
first group you got to remember was 783.
I didn't know that 1988 like my first
gold record was colors 783 Madman World
in the movie colors so I signed with 783
in 88 and we was um so we assigned to
rush management
Russell yeah and um we're doing Stadium
tours
we're open enough for salt and pepper
opening up for Hammer opening up for
Tony Tony Hammer yeah we was on the tour
with hammer Tony Tony and today what's
the MC Hammer toy like back then
stadiums crazy as [__] like I don't
think people understand like he was like
a [__] like pop star for real I have
an MC Hammer Barbie doll I'm talking you
see my MCM or Barbie's sitting down yeah
talking you know 25 000 people a night
and it's doing stadiums mans you know
and then um salt and pepper Kwame was on
the tour wow so you know just being
young and then I would come back to
Cyprus you know and like I'm 18 19 and I
was like yo
figuring this music [__] out fellas you
know what I mean so
783 really taught me about the music
business and I just brought all that
[__] knowledge back to Cyprus because
there was no Google or right no even
even to learn the DJ had to go to the
club and watch the DJ and [__] listen
to the radio that's how I learned there
was no
scratch Academy no [__] right none of
that you just had to really just learn
on the job let's watch and try to
remember and figure it out was I always
heard MC Hammer everyone always says
Hammer's like a real ass dude for real
for real like he's certified like but
but you also hear like he always had
like a big entourage with him oh he had
a big ass Entourage yeah like you you'd
come on the stage just you know your
little hype man and and and maybe one
little dancer and he'd come out with
like 16 dancers crazy you know I mean in
a hype man I was like little John back
then yeah like screaming and [__]
talking [__] so
yeah that was crazy man it was it was it
was a good experience to have those
tours you know and then with Cypress
you're like I already knew I already
knew what's going to happen I was like
the success is waiting for us in the
future we just got to get to it fellas I
was going to say for you though
um how what are the things that you
could give advice to somebody who's an
independent artist maybe has like a
modest following how can they really
monetize music now because I feel like
it's not what it used to be streaming
doesn't pay the greatest well you got to
build a career man so I think I think
you got a tour you got to go do shows
man even if you're not getting paid you
go play in front of nine people yeah
always the Wonder plays the next time
you play in front of 20 next time you
play in front of 35 yeah you know in two
years it'll be 150 people there yeah so
the energy of the shows make sure you
have your merch and you join your
pop-ups and you're live on it and you're
live on social media talking to your
people you know and then doing your
streaming and um be consistent and I
think all that [__] together you you put
that together and you stay consistent
you build a career you know some
[__] just want to like
stream [__] and maybe they might get a
show in New York and then that's it
flashing a pan [__] or you might get a
show and then they don't they get money
there but they don't want to go do shows
in other cities because there's no bread
but I was like you got to go plant the
flag bro you gotta you gotta build the
fan base you got to go build it I always
tell people like just because you have a
big song doesn't mean you have a big
following this [__] there's people who
have platinum records that can't sell a
[__] concert ticket period like and
that's going to tell you where you're
what fans you really have man is it like
are you actually getting streams because
you have features or are you getting
streams because you have fans that
really love you and then that's going to
translate to those people will come out
and you know support you they'll Buy the
T-shirt
so a lot of that [__] it's a little
pumped up you know what I mean when you
got a lot of features on your records
because you'll see all you don't you
can't sell a hard ticket outside you
can't even sell a hard ticket in your
city you can only get on shows with
[__] I was going to ask you uh
you tell me the story on how you and
Alchemist met and how he became a part
of the uh when he was like 13 I had his
manager
um and today was like hey you want to
make a lot of money and I was like well
when you talk about six so we got this
little rap group
two little white kids from Beverly Hills
you know they get that [__] the [__]
out of here yeah it was James constant
yeah I didn't meet him I didn't see him
I was just like the concept of that [__]
was like were you trying to do like a
crisscross yeah but a white people house
of pain I was like
so I think they ended up bringing him to
be real and be real work with them but
then I met Al and I was like oh this is
kid's cool as [__] he reminds me of me
like just like just tenacious [__]
worker like worker and just the love and
the [__] and smart and just work and
work and work and just on point I was
like okay I'm gonna give this kid access
and let him be around and then like I'm
gonna just cut all this [__] you have to
go through and just put you right here
you with the biggest group in the world
now in the studio going on tour hanging
out you know what I mean and just like
give him access because I knew all she
needed to do was be around it he's such
a [__] smart kid and such a sponge
you'll figure it out you know what I
mean just give him access to the [__]
was it um was he always wanting to step
away from rapping and just focus on
producing when I met him he didn't make
beat [__] okay and then when he did that
first time there was they wasn't they
weren't here I mean of course he was
learning yeah he was really he was a
real Premier fan and and it was just
like you know some c-level Premiere like
kid [__] he was just I'd be like nah
that's not it bro but you knew like I
always knew Al has that that that's it
that it thing that special [__] thing
like he's just [__] whatever Al decided
he wanted to do he was going to be
successful in it you know what I mean
he's just that smart and that [__]
that that much of a hard worker and that
got that much Focus so you know we just
brought him put him under my wing it's
like you know he starts seeing how
records albums are made how Studio
sessions are run you know and the little
tricks the little behind the [__] going
on tour with us carrying the carrying
the crates and [__] you know what I mean
you're on [__] big Festival tours you
know I mean at [__] 15 years old
leaving school yeah crazy and then
eventually you know now he's he's
Alchemists grab your nominate God is the
illest in the game right now man I I
agree man I I was just saying like his
like last couple year run has been like
so crazy like you think about the stuff
he's done with boldie with Freddy like
he's just been just Relentless he hasn't
done nothing different he's been working
this hard all these years it just you
know it's just timing it's just it's the
perfect storm you know it's like the way
the music is and the way the the uh what
we like
culture's growing and then just the
right artists at the right times with
all the momentum he's built up over the
years you know what I'm saying I was
gonna ask you um your production process
how much has it changed over the years
because back in the day everybody we
have their go-to equipment nowadays like
I'll like know guys who I never ever
thought would touch like
digital platform like who will only be
on Ableton or they're only Beyond Pro
Tools like what is your yeah it was the
same for me man I was using the sp12 I
moved over to the MPC and then it just I
wanted to do some electronic [__] for
fun and I was like how do you do this
[__] and like oh I can't do it on this
ship I got to learn this [__]
computer and I was like I was the last
[__] bro to [__] with the
computer like you were hanging on to the
I was hanging on a two inch everything
yeah and I was just like [__] it so I
just took a year and just worked on some
electronic music and just took a year
and just dialed just worked on the
machine until I figured out like oh I
can get my sound out of this thing
because it turned into a lot more um
sound design and then you know getting
into the [__] the the effects yeah
there's plugins for everything yeah and
I haven't haven't not having to have a
big studio and learn everything and
[__] plugging everything in and just
having it right there my fingertips I
was like I actually it started getting
fun again for me it's super fun again
you know and then and then my my
daughter got to a certain age where I
was like oh I don't gotta [__] be
there all the time so you know it was
like six years ago it's when I was like
oh it's about me again now it's my time
kids are raised shit's all good all
right y'all I love everybody but it's my
time I'm gonna be greedy now it's the
most freeze I've ever dive in dive right
back in so I think we've done like you
know 34 35 projects in the last six
years